Can take off the role with the makeup
and the costume.
Um,
obviously if you've,
uh,
play player a bit,
that has tremendous moment,
they know that doesn't just leave you.
I remember once actually was here on
Broadway,
I was in Martin Sherman play bent,
which was an extraordinary love story.
Again,
a very daring and you know,
pushing the envelope drama about,
um,
homosexuals in a sent to a camp and I'm
dark and dangerous.
But at the core of it,
this wonderful story,
human monetarian story of love between
two unlikely man.
Um,
great play.
And One night there was a young girl at
the stage door and uh,
she said,
uh,
oh,
I came to the play tonight with my
mother and I and I,
she says,
my mother was in a concentration camp
and under some of the things described
in the play,
terrible things happen to her.
And I went cold.
I thought,
oh my God,
what is this girl going to say?
How dare you,
you know,
welfare act to trivialize or miss,
to reduce her experience,
her memories.
Instead,
she said,
I'd just like to thank you.
She's,
my mother has never been able to talk
about the experience.
But seeing the play was like a key.
It unlocked the experience for her.
And she's talking about it for the first
time,
and I thought,
my God,
you know,
this is,
this is the drama.
As we said earlier,
going back to that,
it's Greek origins,
you know,
as being sort of sacred,
therapeutic,
uh,
experience.
And I thought,
well,
you know,
if I never do anything else,
then
this one night is valuable.